selon sa position sur le spectre visible.
Ainsi, par exemple, le rouge est plus productif que le bleu.
Si j'entends ça en tant que designer :
une surface colorée, une surface en verre coloré,
la couleur, qui est surtout utilisée pour l'esthétique,
tient désormais une autre fonction et peut produire de l'électricité,
je pense, où peut-on bien en trouver une application ?
Voici la Current Table,
dont tout le plateau est composé de ces cellules solaires colorées.
Il y a des batteries dans les pieds
où on peut charger son téléphone grâce à des ports USB.
Dans mon travail, il est toujours crucial
de trouver un équilibre entre efficacité et esthétique.
Cette table est orange
car il s'agit d'une couleur très stable pour les intérieurs.
Ce qu'on me demande le plus souvent, c'est :
« OK, super, mais combien de téléphones peut-on charger avec ? »
Avant d'entrer dans des réponses complexes du type :
« Où se trouve la table, reçoit-elle assez de soleil
est-elle à côté de la fenêtre ? »
La table a reçu des capteurs mesurant l'intensité lumineuse de la pièce.
Grâce à une application qu'on a développée,
on peut connaître la quantité de lumière reçue
et le niveau de charge de la batterie.
J'en suis très fière, car, hier, nous avons installé la table
dans les bureaux de la fondation DOEN, à Amsterdam,
et, en ce moment même,
la reine Maxima charge son portable en utilisant cette table.
C'est cool.
(Applaudissements)
Donc, plus vous avez de surface, plus vous pouvez produire de l'électricité.
Voici les Curent Windows,
nous avons remplacé toutes les fenêtres d'une galerie londonienne de Soho
par cette version moderne du vitrail.
Les gens dehors peuvent charger leur portable
dans les rebords de la fenêtre.
Je donne une fonction supplémentaire aux objets.
Une fenêtre peut devenir plus qu'une simple fenêtre.
Elle peut aussi servir de petite centrale électrique.
Je vous parle de mon amour pour l'énergie solaire,
mais je n'ai pas de panneaux solaires sur mon toit.
Je vis dans le centre d'Amsterdam,
dans un immeuble classé qui ne m'appartient pas,
ce n'est ni possible, ni autorisé.
Donc comment rendre l'énergie solaire plus accessible à tous,
et pas uniquement aux gens qui peuvent se permettre un mode de vie écolo ?
Nous pouvons maintenant
intégrer l'énergie solaire là où nous en avons directement besoin.
Il y a tellement de technologies incroyables sur le marché.
En regardant autour de moi, je vois que chaque surface est une possibilité
Par exemple, je circulais en train à travers le Westland,
le lieu qui concentre toutes les serres des Pays-Bas.
J'y ai vu tout ce verre et j'ai pensé :
et si on y incorporait des panneaux solaires transparents ?
Et si on combinait l'agriculture traditionnelle
qui demande beaucoup d'énergie
avec la technologie de pointe ?
C'est dans cette optique que j'ai créé Power Plant
avec une équipe d'architectes et d'ingénieurs.
Je vais d'abord vous expliquer comment cela fonctionne.
Nous utilisons des panneaux solaires transparents
pour alimenter son atmosphère intérieure.
L'agriculture hors-sol permet de recycler l'eau et ses nutriments,
économisant 90% de la consommation d'eau.
En empilant des couches, on peut augmenter le rendement par mètre carré.
En plus de la lumière du soleil, ces LED colorées produisent plus de lumière,
ce qui aide aussi la plante à pousser.
De plus en plus de gens vont vivre dans des grandes villes.
En installant des Power Plants sur les toits,
nous ne devrons plus les exporter de l'autre bout du monde,
nous pourrons les cultiver sur place.
Mon rêve est de les installer dans des lieux hors réseau –
où il n'y a ni accès à l'eau, ni à l'électricité –
comme un écosystème indépendant.
Pour la biennale de design de cette année,
j'ai créé le premier modèle de Power Plant de 4 mètres de haut,
où il est possible de venir voir comment poussent les plantes.
C'est donc une double récolte de lumière solaire,
pour les panneaux solaires et pour les plantes.
C'est comme un jardin botanique du futur,
où nous glorifions toutes ces technologies modernes.
Le plus beau compliment reçu était : « Mais où sont les panneaux solaires ? »
J'ai alors pensé que le design fonctionne vraiment
quand il devient invisible et qu'on ne le remarque pas.
Je crois en la démocratie solaire :
l'énergie solaire pour tous, partout.
Mon objectif est de rendre toutes les surfaces productives.
Je veux bâtir des maisons où les fenêtres, les rideaux, les murs
et même le plancher produisent de l'électricité.
Pensez à plus grande échelle :
dans les villes, il y a tellement de surfaces.
Le soleil est accessible à tout le monde.
En intégrant l'énergie solaire là où on en a besoin,
nous pouvons désormais rendre les panneaux solaires accessibles à tous.
Avec vous, je veux rapprocher l'énergie solaire des gens,
sous une forme belle et bien conçue.
Merci.